okay first of all hey guys nice to meet
you
um let's start with josh so betty was
your self-proclaimed best friend in the
house but yet you chose kevin over her
twice
when did you decide you were taking him
to the end and why
i want to start pretending i'm a huge
fan of you and i decided to take kevin
um
honestly a few days before the final uh
the finale i thought i had a better
chance against kevin i thought people
didn't know his game that well uh just
me and helena did and so he didn't have
a lot of competition with so i was like
there's no way i won't win this
okay okay okay
uh betty
you said you accepted josh's decision if
it made sense for his game but from your
perspective what seemed to be his
strategy in cutting you
honestly i wish i knew i think now
looking back i understand that he
thought he had a better chance to win
this game against kevin but in the back
of my mind i knew josh was going to take
it home if he would have taken me i
think i probably just should have
vocalized that a little bit more in the
final three
josh knowing what you know now do you
think the jury would have voted for you
if you had taken betty
i have had a chance to chat with the
jury and it would have been very close
split between me and betty but probably
in my favor
yeah betty for you how do you think the
votes would have fallen if josh would
have taken you over kevin
i honestly looking back i probably think
i may have squeezed one or two votes but
i think the majority of them would have
been for josh yeah
josh you led your final speech with an
apology to the jury um why did you feel
like that was necessary
i knew that i had hurt a lot of people
in this game and i wanted them to know
how truly sorry i was about that i came
into this game and developed a really
strong personal connections with a lot
of people in the house and ultimately
that was my downfall as much as it was
my strength and so i truly just wanted
them to know how i felt about that
yeah
um betty so josh picking kevin over you
twice this season has that changed the
way you view your friendship with him i
know you're sitting beside him but
what's going on yeah um you know what i
know it's just a game at the end of the
day uh i would be lying if i said i
wasn't a little salty um i think that in
the house we were definitely best
friends outside of the house who knows
what's going to happen yeah maybe maybe
not
were you so like surprised by how close
josh and kevin like really were
yeah honestly i knew that they were
close but you know after i was sharing
with josh like my god feelings about
kevin being a schemer and knowing that
kevin would cut josh um especially when
i was hoh i really thought that i had
talked some sense into him but i think
my downfall was probably not
continuously repeating the conversation
um and like reiterating it constantly i
guess he needed that
yeah um for you josh you hid your job
from the house guests the entire time
you posed as a marine biologist
instead of your job as a doctor um do
you think anyone was on to you and knew
you were lying
absolutely not there nobody had any clue
kevin would ask the right questions and
on day one he came hard with them but i
think i deflected them pretty well yeah
yeah okay
um betty you're the first black woman on
big brother canada to make it to the
third place um how does it feel to go
from a five-time um eviction nominee to
making bb can
history
it feels incredible i am so proud of
what i was able to accomplish uh in my
time at bbcan
as an ethiopian woman i just hope that i
represented the community well um you
know i really wish i would have been in
that final two spot but at the end of
the day i'm so grateful for how far i
came yeah
if you guys could sum up your bb can
experience into one word what would it
be
um
oh yeah uh
chaotic
[Laughter]
destructive
that's a good that's a good match well
it was so nice talking to you guys and
still congratulations regardless thank
you
you